foreign
[Applause]
so it's been three years since we last
saw shuri so what was it like returning
to her and what can we expect from her
in wakanda forever it was really
exciting to return to Black Panther
wakanda forever it was exciting to
represent and be a vessel for sure again
going through her own process
um and we meet her at a time where she's
learning about how tough life can be you
know and and we see a shift in in that
in that spark that we met in the first
film we see something going on there and
we were unpacking it in this film so it
was really it was really interesting to
go deeper a little bit with her I'm very
excited to see that so you're the sister
of the Black Panther yes you may or may
not be the New Black Panther we wouldn't
know
um but Kevin feige did lay out the next
few phases of the MCU and has introduced
you know younger versions of Heroes
we've already seen there's like Bishop
Miss Marvel in this movie we're gonna
see einhardt do you see sure as part of
the next generation of superhero teens
with their own group I would love for
that to happen I think Kevin is the best
person to talk to
it's a great answer so one thing that I
love about Black Panther is that there's
a really strong female characters and in
this movie it's gonna be you know
dominant female cast
um Ryan does such an amazing job at
redefining you know motherhood what's it
like to be a sister and I want to know
what's it like for you to be part of
this movement of creating a stronger
female presence in the MCU I love it
it's beautiful it's a way for us to
encourage so many women and young girls
around the world it's empowering it's
liberating
and to show ways in which women can come
together on screen is something that
we've been waiting for for a long time
and to see that it could birth new films
and new ideas in the future
um it's really beautiful so yeah I'm I'm
honored to be a part of it so you once
described this movie as you know a love
letter to the late traffic Boseman
um can you share more about that and how
is that carried through throughout this
movie oh man when I say this is a love
letter to him for me
um it's all way of in my way as as
Sherry to
to pull my heart into the story and into
the film to make sure that every time
I'm on set I do it with excellence and
to pour like all of my love for him into
into the fibers of the of the story Into
the fibers of the character so those are
the ways in which
um I feel like this is a love letter to
him and I feel like hopefully you guys
will think the same when you finish
watching it I've watched the trailers
and he made me cry so I know I know the
movie's Gonna Make Me Crazy up now the
movie looks incredibly action-packed and
unfortunately you got injured I'm glad
you're doing so much better now thank
you um but I was filming this action
sequence is like oh man we have
so many great action in this movie
everybody's you know pulling up
um and giving a hundred percent and I
think it's it's a part of the universe
right you can't have Marvel without
action so I'm really excited to see what
you guys think of of the sequences and
and the ways in which everybody's you
know protecting the nation out of
everything what are you most proud of
about this movie
I'm proud of a lot
I'm proud of us as a team and as a
family
that we stay together through through
everything
um you know it's been a tough time to
lose our brother but we stay together
and we made something beautiful and now
we can share it with you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
and my entire family is gone
have I not given everything
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]